For this assignment, discuss how you'd use frames to
represent Raven's Progressive Matrices. At a basic level, what are the slots and
fillers associated with different Raven's problems? Where are these frames going
to come from? Is the agent going to receive the problem in terms of frames
initially, or it going to generate these frames based on its own reasoning?
Once it has these frames, what exactly are the reasoning methods it's going to
use to solve the problem based on these frames?
We've also talked about frames representing individual figures from the problem.
But what about a frame representing the problem,
as a whole? What about a frame representing individual shapes within figures?
How would representing the problems at that different level of abstraction,
help the agents solve the problem more easily.
What are frames going to enable us to do, that we couldn't do otherwise?